[Music]
every answer generates further
questions I want to point out first that
I'm very happy to be here this
[Music]
evening
TR his
[Music]
my come on I'll teach you
again
[Music]
uhoh you're too Wicked for me you don't
understand what
[Music]
is
beul that's what she
[Music]
said
don't be a
victim try the Walther you'll be glad
you did
and I don't really have time for General
so please leave me
alone their primary goals is one acquire
as much us land as you can and number
two gather as much and collect US
currency as
possible president XI has publicly
stated that the West is declining and
China is
ascending am I it was foed upon us bye
again to some degree and by some I mean
all degree the Communist Chinese
government they have 60 green houses and
make one family for Greenhouse to run it
each family had a 10x 10
[Music]
room
[Applause]
[Music]
what I
know
[Music]
call me
gorlock I don't want to you'll call me
gorlock and you'll like it
gorlock just that's for the soundboard
hey my question to you before we get to
what are your thoughts on constitutional
carry because this is an area where
sometimes people don't fully understand
uh where they line up as conservatives
in federalism do you think it's a state
issue spoiler it's not that's
foreshadowing that's what yeah yeah you
can call me Steinbeck um Steinbeck we
have
a uh we have a lot to get to here today
and tomorrow by the way is the special
on the Oklahoma grow farms and the
Communist Chinese party buying up
American land uh and if you want more of
that of course you can always support us
at uh you know mug Club none of this
investigative journalism happens without
you so today we'll be talking about um
the squad's really bad
week I don't know at what point people
should be deported for treason but I
think we've I think look behind you
there's the line constitutional carry
and their effects on crime rates this is
it always gets worse where they say
Republicans conservatives don't want to
study gun crime no no we don't want you
to politicize it whenever there's an
objective study they go crap so uh in
Ohio we know the results uh take a guess
and then um we're going to be talking
about a longevity Guru who wants to
change Humanity in crazy ways and
gorlock the
Destroyer is a desert deserter that'll
make sense when you that's fitting when
you get to it how are you doing number
to Captain Morgan I'm doing better I
feel like i' I've turned a bit of a
corner I still sound bad or or good
depending yeah I now I have it again you
do but it was you said you had a sore
throat I didn't have a sore throat I
just have a voice that sounds like I
have a sore throat so I didn't give it
to you it's not all about you Gerald I
have a sore throat yeah but you're
trying to blame me
so yes third chair when you hear
this you know who it is and uh Friday
Saturday March 1st and 2nd he's going to
be at the Louisville Comedy Club you can
see all his other dates brian.com and
watch the show here on mug Club off
limits every Tuesday Mr K how are you
groundbreaking podcast off limits yes
groundbreaking Louis Louisville come out
um only if you like laughing hard
without breaks for over an hour you know
what I mean Stephen yeah also if you
hate yourself and want to spend time in
Louisville that's well Hey listen the
camed Club is great it is great the city
is awful I watched a man die did you
watch a man die yeah well I watched them
try to revive a man who did with Naran
I've done that after I choke him out in
Jitsu this was a man's life Brian oh is
that what it was no laughing matter okay
I'm sorry not everything's a joke I
think it was interesting that Stephen
said something he said I have a little
tickle in my throat and I think it's
because I'm allergic to uh feathers and
I thought myself well my thought Cloud
was that's the gayest thing I've ever
heard in my life yeah might be yeah yeah
but it's okay I don't mean to gayest
thing I've ever heard in my life is
talking about choking out a homeless man
in Kentucky because it's thoughtless I
never and it's inconsiderate homeless
you mean unhoused neighbor yes sorry
guys yeah the progressive meter just hit
red hot here I agree he's doing the
whole Ma you know population control get
rid of the unhoused neighbors yes yeah
like a good neighbor homeless rapist is
there let's go
to gorlock the Destroyer gorlock the
Destroyer I had to intro that I'm sorry
so this is making the rounds here uh a
massive trans influencer oh by the way
before I go into anything I should say I
was to say at some point today which
will probably happen during this segment
you see or hear
this head on over to rumble because we
want to be on YouTube anyway we won't
self- censor uh but you know you can
still watch it there because it burns to
head to rumble for some of you so a
massive trans influencer someone would
say rotund portly massive double on
Tandra Ali lope Lopez uh commonly
referred to as you probably know this
person as gorlock the Destroyer one does
oh yeah uh this went viral yesterday
with this trans activist complaining
about the lack
of masculine men oh boy a lot of men
expecting women in the relation
especially when they're in committed
relationships already like they expect
the women to go above and
beyond and like them just almost do
nothing and I feel like it's something
that I see a lot outside of social media
I also love when like there is a little
bit of like a a little bit of a gender
role in a relationship I don't I don't
I'm not a big fan of toxic masculinity
or like yeah whatever like the the Norms
I guess but I like when there's just
like a little bit of that like I'm the m
and I'm G to take charge you know what
like cuz like why not you know I feel
like a lot of being boys though like
when it comes to like the male roles
because a lot of
like expecting princess treatment and
it's like okay well I want that energy
just as much as but just as bad as you
do for example like let's say I get a
flat tire on the side of the road eat it
and we're together you better know how
to change that
tire you better know how to change that
tire do these things cuz if I have to
call my dad just like I said he wouldn't
answer he's not coming no no no sorry
babe yeah sorry babe don't rush into
anything enjoy your time being single
because I feel like that's when you
learn the most about yourself but that
cook it down very much that because you
always want to see what kind of person
you are
alone well you really get to see what
kind of person you are so hey hold on
I'll change the tire when you grow some
tits let's start with that oh can I say
something nice no I don't want you to
let me get this off my chest
[Music]
first
p
[Music]
oh
p
[Music]
up
p
[Music]
get the first part right f
10 I mean I'm just saying when everybody
in the coms is going to say be like oh
yeah
like is there a comma somewhere in in
that statement I hope not it would have
to be a
semicolon I just feel that's a it's a
little narcissistic it's a little
narciss little bit I'm not going to I'm
not going to give that person a 10 but
you know good personality really you're
not that's your problem just saying
everyone else thinks I'm a 10 some
people even say 11 which is super cool
because the scale only goes up to 10
well celebrity is something like when I
was doing a TV show somebody said to me
you're not a good-look guy because
you're on TV you rank up there with
firemen I thought that was pretty cool
no firemen are gross I want a
billionaire with a Bugatti who can
change a
tire that's you should be okay with a
but a high and tight a fade and only
your top button done that's go be who
you are
now Brian Johnson you guys are going to
let me just hang there yeah just a
little bit I was going to call you a
hair Nazi hey comment hit the like
button like if you this is what is it
funny sure is it gross absolutely yeah
but this is really where we
[Music]
are
so let's move on to like what you
gestured cuz you had you cup you were
cupping something that's what you do
with a tan bro at the end of the day
this is what you got you take care of a
then you cherish it my femininity like a
princess I ate the princess you got 177%
of this I'm a princess look at me like a
peach all right yeah so we'll move move
on with more horrible advice that is
being and this is the problem with the
algorithm you know we always if you want
to know watch the show tune in check the
references we make them available then
leave the algorithm is an artificial
brain and only because of this algorithm
do you see things like that presented as
anything other than the bearded lady and
it's the same as it relates to health
advice so if you're not familiar with
this uh aging and lifestyle Guru Brian
Johnson here's a quick
refresher right now is the very first
time in human history where you can say
with a straight face you may not die you
believe that oh there's no question it's
hard to believe Tech millionaire Brian
Johnson is 46 years old but no matter
his chronological AG he's striving for
the biological age of an 18-year-old his
team of 30 doctors utilize all the
latest tech the plan is rigorous now
here's the thing none of this would
matter if thousands of people weren't
following this guy's advice yeah so
weird Health hacks like uh he does
plasma trans fusions uh he getss them
from his son he takes 111 daily
supplements that's a good idea it only
gets weirder he advocates for genital
shock therapy commonly known as staring
at this picture of gorlock so that's the
yeah think it works he measures his
number of nighttime erections oh so he's
got to put something on a Contraption on
his penis yes right I would suppose it's
like a cack machine but unless he's
waking up every time Don't Wake Daddy
hitting the ticker in which case you're
ruining your sleep got like an Apple
Watch he's got a Night Nurse he's got a
Night Nurse who's always got her hands
around it he has an has an apple shiny
ring oh you so
big nightly erection after Today's show
if I wore the Apple wiener ring it would
be dormant all night are you it's like
when Netflix says are you still watching
this ring weener ring it just keeps
falling off as long as it's made of like
alligator yes yeah it's expensive yeah
it is it's more expensive than crocodile
because of the mineral deposit see there
you go the scales and it's more pliable
sorry I not crocodile Cayman admonish me
admonish me Cayman boots are cheaper
than gator boots which is crazy because
they have gator Farms you would think it
wouldn't be yeah there you go right C
now G Cayman a is thick yeah oh boy it's
really hard to find a good good man in
gay
boots C and knockoffs and what's
that lizard if you want to get with me
then make it real all right guys poor
he's got Cayman boots yes and Cayman
cocking I want a hat I want a h i really
really really want I want to I want to
Hostess
so this week now Johnson so all of these
things are being advocated and being
flooded into your children's timelines
that's the problem problem remember
someone out there said that the sauna
would increase your testosterone by 600%
yeah so here's another one Johnson made
some waves now now it extends to uh
these comments and thoughts regarding
Humanity we're right now in a moment at
the last moment where like things kind
of have been how they have been but
they're about to change radically and in
this new future we can't predict what's
going to happen we no longer have the
ability and so we're living Ino world
and so gen zero is a group of
multiethnic multinational people who
rise up and they say we are willing to
courageously step into the
future and we're willing to divorce or
open to divorce from ourselves all human
Norms all human Customs all human
thought and we're willing to say we're
wide
open about everything eyes like a White
laat Blank Slate yeah he hates he hates
uh our species this by that's a guy who
wants to mesh with machines right now a
guy who you know who transfused with his
own son's blood which that's the medical
Journal Review
yes it's just like uh by he hates
Humanity but this is you think that guy
hasn't done some Botox or had some face
work done I mean he wants you to believe
it's because he measures his nighttime
boners look like this this is all
natural this is because I do genital
shock therapy you can't say the laugh
lines no because you're joyless now
eight those are rookie numbers you got
to pump that up yes you do God and he's
shaved down he's got somebody who shaves
him with a straight razor I'm so turned
on right I mean I'm so grossed out yeah
I know yeah yeah I think there's
something very strange about this
longevity this a quest for longevity
which is really at the end of the day
you've got to be kind of anti-human cuz
he wants to be the last guy standing if
he can caress the dying faces of
everyone he knows with his lowfat
healthy hand
[Music]
oh
something to Christians you need to
understand when you say like I hate
people no if you're God says you're to
love people to be clear you can be
annoyed by people but you are to love
people this man hates people and this by
the way mirrors exactly what you will
see from all of these atheist communist
regimes of all time this this exact is
tried in pole Poots C it was called year
zero it sounds familiar Generation Z yep
year zero they eliminated all culture
tradition right that was a part of it
they outlawed private property religious
practice they uh dur like Mar Rouge 1.7
million people died which doesn't sound
like a lot when you compare to but
that's
21% of the population and they weren't
just killing people because they were
Jews or they were handicapped they were
killing people because they wore glasses
yes smart people they were intellectuals
yes the idea was always that we can
create Utopia on earth right and that is
the most dangerous thing because if
you're going to try to create Utopia on
Earth you're trying to perfect human
beings and you're getting rid of all
their imperfections and then the problem
is you have a lot of people that are
already beyond that they've been they've
been too indoctrinated you can't change
them with a re-education camp so they
have to go we have to remove that that
was that was the Communist mentality
just like that was now that's what Paul
pot did that's what all of them did yeah
well The Killing Fields had a they
actually had a killing tree infants and
other uh people they they were just
bashed to death against the tree because
at a certain point too communism doesn't
work totalitarianism doesn't work so
they don't have the money to kill people
effectively and I don't know if you
remember this too this happened with MAO
by the way the problem is when you
determine that humanity is a problem it
has to be one person one voice
determining how humanity is a problem
and how to fix it then these people get
too entrenched in their lies like I
don't know General shock therapy adding
a few months to your life with ma
remember they said it was actually the
problem with all of this famine it's uh
it's all of these sparrows that's what
they said yeah he said it was all it was
a sparrows because he had caused the
famine he said no no no no no Sparrow
Sparrow caused no fool CA kill Sparrow
solve problem so people killed all the
sparrows wow which then of course
brought in more insects which created
more famine and they had you know how
they killed The Sparrows they would bang
pots and pans right until sparrows
wouldn't land which is cruel they're
about like bangang bang oh yeah but
you know we got to remember remind you
got to remind people Larry pagee who was
the founder of Google accused Accu when
when Elon Musk was raising the dangers
of AI making Ai and he said what do you
this is not good for Humanity and Larry
pagee said something to the effect of
don't be such a or oh I see you're aist
yeah meaning you favor the human species
over everything else which means
equivalent to being a racist right so so
what's to say that meshing with machines
sensient machines isn't A Better Way
Forward and maybe our this sort of Rusty
biological IC Heritage needs to go by
the wayside yeah and that is that's a
Godless notion the idea playing God we
can be God and then every now and then I
listen to them and then I see gorlock
the Destroyer uh the destroyer and say
you know what maybe they have a point
but then I think of gorlock meshing with
machine that's not a Mech Warrior that I
want to see no I don't think she meshes
she just Pacific Rim huh she just
absorbs the machine mug Club you can
smash that button right now join mug
Club tomorrow we have more investigative
journalism going on uh and uh none of
this happens you have Brian show you
have the hod you have Alex Jones on
Friday uh you have Mr guns and& gear you
have our show on Friday we're adding
more and more in the investigative
journalism unit none of this happens
without you $9 to go mugas now if you
want to try it month to month let's go
on to other uh
anti-human piles of hum human excr
ironically they're anti-human but they
they themselves are are
human yes self lothing although I'm
looking at myself sometimes when the
monitor comes on and then I look at
Brian Johnson I'd like that skin please
I want luminescent skin I want you to
say Brian your skin looks so Lumin you
want to look like one of those creatur
at the bottom of the ocean in the Maran
Mar trench yeah they with a dangling
Lantern to get yeah that's my that's my
Apple wiener ring that's is wor it
charges angler K yes so hot not to be
confused with blob so let me ask you
this we're going to run down the
misdeeds of the dumbest members of
Congress your representatives here um at
what point do you think you reach
treason at what point do you think you
reach almost like desertion if they're
supposed to be represent I know that
everyone wants to say treason right
sedition was people uh taking a walking
tour January 6th and that's an opinion
that you may hold I disagree I think
that when you say I'm looking out for a
foreign Nation not only above the UN the
United States uh but in place of in
other words we've gotten beyond the
point of hey I'm looking out for another
country as well we can all benefit We
Are the World which is horse crap to
begin with but now you're saying I know
that benefiting this country would be
done at the the expense of the country
that I'm supposed to represent I think
that's when you cross over and certainly
everyone in the squad qualifies so this
past week has been a bad one for the
squad plus one because now you have AOC
Elon Omar right Cory Bush Rashid T and
then Jamal Bowman he's like he's he the
plus one well he's Squad adjacent he's
Squad adjacent yeah yes you know I
didn't know Cory Bush was part of the
squad you always forget abouty new
addition no it's not a new addition it's
just Cory bush is like the Joey Bishop
of the
squad like the Rango yeah yeah a little
bit Yeah Ringo where everything is some
aquatic Ringo wrote two songs basically
Yellow Submarine and Under the Sea yeah
good s wait Tred to write a third one
and it was called like uh in the lake
and they're like where's everything
aquatically
themed I've had it with you it's my
Niche it's who I
am you suck
Liverpool I only go forward I'll go
forward in the aquatic theme I'm like a
shark I can't go back Ringo what is it
with you okay
so and I know this because of my with my
my little children at bath time I always
find myself singing another Ringo song
like damn it yeah so catchy yeah like
Yellow Submarine cuz he have one and I'm
like what what you want me to sing next
like under under the sea I'm like damn
it Ringo yellow submar you were the
original cocoa
melon so Corey Bush here's one we're
Squad okay we're going to go through a
really really bad week uh I think these
people are are gu of treason
collectively can we we can charge them
collectively uh Cory bush is now under
federal investigation for misuse uh of
funds here's a clip in recent months
right-wing organizations have lodged
baseless complaints against me pedling
Notions that I have misused campaign
funds to pay for personal security
services that simply is not true okay so
we have the reference there from CNN
that's what's Alle her phone there hate
or husband for security yeah should read
off her
like I did not pay my husband I did not
pay my husband for security which now
that I say that out loud should probably
be doing it for free but I'm a by
by the way texted her let me just be
clear she admits to paying her husband
through her campaign and says it's
totally fine because he's had experience
yeah doing stuff like that I mean I
don't whatever just you know he should
do it for free so or you know what maybe
not brilliant Ploy what's the male
equivalent to a gold
digger it's kind of hot though I think
that gorlock is looking for a dude
that's the kind of traditional mail I
like someone who who'll in the line of
fire me but I got to pay him
right need like three in the line of
fire carry me out like a bodyguard only
it'll be with a free Willie hammock just
have a big pocket and she just tips him
yes it's free but she just gives him she
goes thanks for making me feel safe
today that's a 20 now the husband is of
course not licensed to provide security
uh nor do I understand is particularly
good at it uh Bush Justified that she
needs the extra protection which may be
true despite uh being one of the loudest
voices uh to
defund that's right the police yeah so
if I end up spending 200,000 if I spend
10 10 10 more dollars on it you know
what I get to be here to do the work so
suck it up and defunding the police has
to happen we need to defund the police
and put that money into social safety
nets because we're trying to save lives
after that all the biscuits were gone at
Red Lobster yeah they were by the social
safety nets fantastic let's have a
social worker provide you your safety I
don't know just I I'm sorry that you
you've laid the ground rules she said
social worker should be called out more
than the police that's I'm Cory
Bush and it's scampy season I gotta get
my ass you think I'm going to go there
without security it's like Lord of the
Flies with all you can eat shrimp it's
not like they ran out of steak at the
Golden Corral okay yeah that always
results in a
fight sneeze Shield is just
blood uh multi-purpose now we have AOC
so we go from uh Cory Bush to AOC uh AOC
said that uh funding needed to be
ongoing needed to continue for the un's
refugee Works Administration the unrwa
okay unra let's go with that this is
what she said cutting off support to
unra the the primary source of
humanitarian Aid to 2 million Gins is
unacceptable among an organization of
13,000 un Aid workers risking the
starvation of millions over grave
allegations of 12 is indefensible the US
should restore Aid immediately so she
said 12 like there were only 12 B actors
um the problem is this came after
reports um that linked
1200 uh unrwa workers to Hamas or
Palestinian Islamic Jihad
1200 and then 12 specifically rated
Israel on October 7th with those attacks
yes so it's like 12 were the special
forces of anti-Semitic terrorism 1 1200
were like you go kill supporting them
yeah yeah 12,000 sorry sorry 12 12,000
12,000 12,000 yes 12,000
12,000 see that was me being 12,000
that's me Mr Conservative 100 of the
12,000 employees just multiples at this
so it's only 10% only 10% 10% don't
spoil the whole oh no that's they do
when it's genocide yeah that's enough
yeah a lot here 12,000 is a lot of yes
it is and then the UR NWA uh the schools
that are run by them they glorify
actively killing Jews oh boy um and uh
you know these schools have been used by
militants in the war so here you go uh
just you know this this is just 12
people again if all 12 if let's say all
12 were teachers that would be enough
like it was a if if it happened to be a
public school in you know in in
Lynnwood perhaps or in in Englewood
Englewood I Hawthorne because you I'm
using your Los Angeles real estate lingo
with adjacent it's Beach adjacent so if
this were a public school in a bad area
of town I would say defund it if there
were 12 teachers saying you know kill
stab all the Jews right right cuz
because I think we're all anti that very
anti- stabbing of Jews generally
generally generally speaking the rule
the
[Music]
exception
our learning at the unra unrwa uh
schools here's a
clip in the
on audio it's all
bad they're just clearing their they
teach us that Jews are fickle bad
people I don't believe that young man is
of age to get a license I also think I
also think they're speaking in metaphor
guys can I just say yes it might be a
metaphor yeah and by the way your
propaganda is not even good like we we
are taught that Jews are fickle bad
people just say just tell the kids
they're cheap send them to a Jewish toy
store and then that'll plant a seed and
then they'll that's how you grow hate
yeah but fickle fickle is not a terrible
thing like you know it's like you guys
are I feel you're rather fickle yes I
first you have to explain to a child
what fickle means I know that's a big
word to get them to be upset by it yeah
fickle a yeah yeah it's almost like I
could I could handle that if you told me
I was fickle I oo that kind of hurts my
feeling but I can work on that yeah just
tell them like the Jews want to take
blippy away yeah like I'm not going to
be like you're fickle why'd you stab him
why'd you stab him he was fickle he was
fickle yeah that's not that's not a
stabbable he wasle what do you do with
fickle Jews we don't stab him I see your
point well that that's why their shows
showed that they killed Mickey Mouse yes
exactly but you're not getting a green
light and D Block it's not like why are
we going to Steve Crowder why are we
going to stab Crowder cuz he was fickle
he was fickle green light him he was
fickle that's what you do with the fix I
say I call them fix cuz I don't have
time to say fickle so there are a bunch
of countries now including the United
States
who are suspending funding to the unrwa
but AOC thinks that that's a travesty uh
of Justice there are also unconfirm
confirmed reports here um so I have to
say uncon unconfirmed to be clear that
uh alleged AOC is demanding restore
funding for the Hitler Youth Foundation
the bin lad and Freedom Camp in a sequel
to the all girl Ghostbusters so it's
like she can't even get one right
accidentally last one was the worst
let's go to Jamal Brown oh the guy who
does he doeses the door plus one yeah
yeah okay
yeah fire fire door guy so he came under
uh scrutiny now for being a 9/11
conspiracy theorist uh there were a
bunch of blog posts that when people say
like Unearthed blog posts I think this
comes from Daily Beast it's really is it
unearthing at this point like you ran a
search online yeah you said Jamal Bowman
blog yeah and you found it yeah they
they it's not like they found it it
wasn't hidden where where the golden
tablets where the moreal treasure Joe
Smith or Joe whatever his name was who
founded the Mormon church it was found
there with the golden taet they make it
sound like Unearthed it Andy duin's like
thick novel like this there's a hollowed
out space where your 911 conspiracy
blogs used to so I was digging I was
digging a post I found he uh he wrote uh
uh quite a bit about 911 uh being a
conspiracy uh including poems like this
2001 planes used as missile Target the
Twin Towers later in the day building 7
also collapsed H multiple explosions
heard before and during the collapse H I
think he meant more like ha horrible h
oh you're like Kanye like H I think the
H is his H he was Jay-Z it'd be oh oh oh
see that's what I'm saying and he
also yeah it that might have been
mistaken as a yummy
sound somebody e a
Butterfinger yeah or like this you
expect it to be bad and then you
go like what that's a I haven't had a
Three Musketeers in a long
time I get it hello what was that about
the juice oh yeah screw them M this is
delicious is that nougat nougat nougat
is the poor man's candy yes nou who
invented nougat they should build a
statue to the guy who invented nougat
and tear it down yes they should I agree
nougat I hate nougat I don't even know
what it is Bowman uh he also promoted
the 911 uh truth of document Loose
Change zeit guys full disclosure Alex
Jones help produce change just to be
clear strows just strange bed fellows
this is what happens and according to
Bowman 911 uh could have easily been
prevented if somebody just pulled a fire
alarm and so you know hey well come on
is that two look two things can be true
ah AI you can never tell if it's real
you can never tell deep fake so real
wait till you see the
pornography with AMA yeah and Bowman and
Bowman small that explains everything
that exp his anger I just thought he
moonlit as a pizza delivery guy hit the
like button if you think that Bowman
makes a good nay the perfect
terrorist speaking of terrorists another
member of the squad Anon Omar now we
talked about this earlier in the week
right yes but now there's an update well
what's the update uh well first off
she's been let's let's refresh here
remember the Somalia first speech here
you
go
[Applause]
now she blamed after this because she of
course was red over the Kohls where uh
Ronda santis D santis said she should be
deported I agree she said it was a poor
translation of the video saying it's not
only it's not only slanted but
completely off I wouldn't expect more
from these propagandists here's the
problem the video with the subtitles
that you saw all references available at
L credit.com for every single show we
provide a bibliography it was
posted by the somal land Deputy Minister
of Foreign Affairs R to J elme this was
from El's tweet the language she Omar
employed was regrettably Unbecoming of
both the office she holds and the
constituents she represents this is
Somali land Somali land not to be
confused with Legoland Som land legol
land they build Somali land they just
blow it up who would go to that theme
park you must have these many bombs area
of Somalia please Somali land come on
Somali land I didn't name it there's a
water park Brian yeah I didn't name it
it's not my fault I'm just saying all
right look you two guys you can hold my
beer because as former governor of
Minnesota I know about Somali land they
were my constituents really it's not a
theme park you trying to be a smartass
right yeah tough guy great yeah thanks
for your service there yeah why don't
you buy me some pizzas yeah you know
what why don't you shut your why don't
you shut your Pizza Hole there Chief I
bet you get some fluoride you need some
how about you come visit me in Mexico in
my
casa it's like it's like a racket ball
court I live minimalist it's four walls
all right we'll both go in one of us
will come out there tough guy okay
Buckaroo I'll give you if if you're a
beton man who do you think's going to be
coming out of there the guy with the
deepest got to be me the Navy SEAL who
was in Predator that's right it was an
underwater demolition unit at that time
to be clear to be clear Mr Mr Maxwell
Smart that's how smart you think you are
you're not clever just keep asking
questions I'll be leaving unscathed
eating
migas got some migas in that di it's
where you crunch up some tortillas and
eggs ass
hat but you wouldn't know cuz your
pineal gland and all the fluide in your
TAP now you have to Santa said she
should be deported uh also keep in mind
that Anon Omar married her brother we
just always want to make sure that you
remember that that's a rumor it's
not I know you're going to hate me for
this but I think she's very attractive
it's
confirmed I want her to yell at me in
Somali no no look look I don't no one
hates you I think less of you but I
don't I think she's I think I've seen
your wife she's beautiful and you think
that ilon Omar hey I'm just saying with
that there's something about her it's
you're virtue signaling with a Pity
compliment I just want to argue with her
about politics and then have makeup sex
right yeah and what do you think gorlock
a
six also while we're talking about
people who are traders to their country
uh honorary Squad member uh Nikki Haley
still works for China I told them that
if they would do this that South
Carolina would wrap their arms around
them and take care of them I now
officially work for you there is nothing
that you can need that we won't make
sure that we deliver how about human
rights fa sorry right clip that is the
correct clip yes so let's let's let's uh
let's uh bring this to a close here this
week you had Squad members who uh have
misused campaign money they've been out
there championing the cause of terrorist
demanding more money for terrorists
waxing poetic about 911 or at least we
discovered that and then of course
putting Somalia first lying about it
saying that's not what I said until the
actual foreign affairs minister of somal
land said that's exactly what that
person said uh so they also lied about
it at what point do you say okay these
people not only are not acting on behalf
of American constituents they're acting
against them I mean think think about
the Boston T the Tea Harbor what
happened to Boston Harbor the tea party
I said Tea
Harbor named it honorar the Boston Tea
Party like they were they were blowing
people away because of attacks on a
morning drink yeah and by the way you
guys also know leather necks that comes
from the fact that they were having a
deal with with piracy some of which
would be S largely the North African
slave trade that's why they would put on
these leather protectors on their neck
that's where the term comes from so it's
not like they weren't aware of it what
do you think would happen with the
founding fathers if they knew that they
had a representative who was not only
demanding money for a place like Somalia
and terrorists but actually funneling it
from a from American Funds they would
have been putting whatever their
equivalent to the boo boxes faster than
you can say rashita claves a terrorist
which she is and I think it's an
important thing to realize that there's
criticism it's one thing to criticize
policy or or the United States if you
actually look at what they're talking
about what they're really doing is
saying if you are within the within the
context of the United States so if
you're within the institutions if you
uphold the institutions that this you
are already guilty so the the solution
is to tear those institutions down
that's that's what we're talking about
here so at the end of the day if you are
a part of the system you're already
corrupt so we have to tear the whole
system down and rebuild it in what well
it's socialism etc those kinds of things
yeah you know what let's go with the
Somali system let's go with the
Palestinian system oh that's right they
throw you off a rooftop little chaotic
or I guess the Somali they'd keelhaul
you probably khaul yeah they'd probably
khaul you horrible way to go more
effective and we're going to talk what's
ke Hall you know keall is where Pirates
they would tie you to a rope and they
would drag you under the bow of the ship
with all the Barnacles and stuff sounds
like a sounds like a crazy CrossFit C
yes it does yeah it's their it's their
metcon for the day yeah it's like the M
we're going to make you do the Sally
it's how you live to 200 for you know Mr
I thought that was the AL no that's 40
kups so
Barnacles um we're going to talk about
the concealed carry law now that says or
at least the study that's come out hey
take a guess how that's going because
this brings us back to our
institutions and you know what look
here's my problem with the squad and my
same problem with uh uh I was going to
say CW gor Gorgonzola what's the name
gorlock gorlock g gorlock
gorlock
c sorry I mean genuine
slip now I want to say gorlock gorlock
and then I was thinking of toy Small
Soldiers the gorguts gorlock the problem
with gorlock is the same problem with
the squad it's the same problem with
people who don't understand
constitutional carry look all of these
people believe that somewhere there's a
culture that deserves to exist for
example multi yes for Somalian culture
yes for Palestinian culture okay then
you have to accept the premise that we
have a culture here in the United States
that is centered on the American family
and by the way the right to own firearms
because that's how we fought off the
world's greatest superpower it does even
if you don't think it's the right
culture I would argue it is it's our
culture and I certainly would say that
it's better than stoning people with a
lisp or throwing women off of rooftops
because they had the nerve to drive
without a man running shotgun that's
what I just accept that it's this
culture why can every you can comment
below why can every country have a
culture yeah and no matter how
homophobic no matter how sexist no
matter no matter how separatist it is
it's okay unless it's the United States
and then we take offense at the idea
that people have the freedom to carry
firearms that people have the freedom to
choose their own Healthcare it's our
culture just accept that like you do
with Somalia and then I would argue that
it's better and I wish Josh actually
thank you for his service was here to
talk about his uh this story that
conceal Carrie where where is he well he
uh I think he just got finished with
with the screen test cuz he was he's
sent us a video of it oh really another
screen test he's really swinging the bat
let's um let's see what he's up to
[Music]
yeah J all right this is a screen test
for Russ whenever you're ready
Josh it's a WRA it's our
guy
[Music]
in the world is J you know what he got
one finally he did yeah grows violation
of firearm safety but that's what
they're looking for and of course the
sponsor of the show The Studio here uh
are they're protected exclusively by
Walther oh that's right you can go to
waltherarms.com you obviously can't buy
them from waltherarms.com but you can
find a dealer near you look there are
great Firearms across the board we've
talked about this uh at a certain point
it comes down to personal preference but
Walther has the balls to sponsor this
show and do me a favor this is the the
wal or PDP just go run us Google bang
bent back paperclip that purple gorilla
whatever it is that you use you can ask
G's Walther PDP review they're great
it's the best kept secret in the in the
firearm industry they just they don't
have these giant military contracts uh
out there so just and you can try it try
the Walther go to a local range Try It
You'll buy it if you have the means I
highly recommend yes yeah yeah Walther
PDP their choice sounds good we're
pretty fortunate that all the sponsors
we have in this which are very few in
far are ones that either heard me
talking about their stuff and they say
hey can we become a sponsor sure we
don't have to go after them and Walther
is uh walther's just one of them they're
awesome all right let's go to the
Constitutional uh carry segment you said
you have a lot for this which you've
been silent most of the day you're hit
your C to cough I know sorry it's it's
tough I can say gorlock everyone I love
the soda in your voice though the soda
you should do perfume ads yeah I should
do some Voice work when I get sick yeah
yes yeah yes you and Omar Calvin
yeah he on I think Calvin Klein is p
right it's no longer is what's a what's
a do Cabana say that I want to hear you
say or Tommy Hill fig say no say yeah do
gabana say it Gerald DOL and gabana oh
my God whoa I'm literally I'm not even
joking it
moved couldn't you just picture that yes
like a sopia len type scenario and a guy
no I picture myself coming out of a of a
of a pond yes with my hair all wet like
there's a difference well you shouldn't
who's the 57-year-old with that golf
physique not a pond that's that's
stagnant water you'd have leeches like a
river okay try it again and just say Bri
Brian Ken as I pull out of the yes say
Brian K wears do and gabana ready I'm
gonna pull out of the water Brian Ken
do I can see you in a ravine see how do
you see how sensual my face is maybe a
basin a basin's a
well a well with a flashlight The Grudge
chick
help me help
me Brian C that's the well that's the I
put strick nine in I was trying to kill
my neighbor the new scent of
fear steid steid I
can't there's nothing I can do then kill
me now give us a dolin goana doin goana
kill
me yeah I'm call you
will hold on give us some music give us
some music
I've been here all night say wet my
mouth I can't drink this water I have
hepatitis but you smell
fantastic and just and just me sinking
under the
water and then Tommy Hil figure comes in
he's like all the blacks get the out of
here dra Noah boy that talk about a
script you guys may not remember that
Tommy Hilfiger was set for life until
one interview he's like yeah I didn't
know all the blacks were going to wear
my
stuff
like
oh too honest Tommy too honest and then
all of a sudden Dillards pulled Tommy
hillfigure yes exact what's his name the
black guy from Shark Tank was putting on
his shirt yeah Dillards Dillards cuz you
know how black that sounds that's
exactly Dillards Dillard for Dillard for
your hip-hop attire yes their new
hip-hop line this fall Hits red hot you
remember that though right the Tommy
Hill figure interview no but I love it
okay someone bring it up for mug Club I
don't know if it was I don't remember if
it was Oprah or some show he's like well
I wouldn't have made it if I knew all
the if I knew it was going to be worn by
all the blacks Chris doll did the same
thing they're like yeah we just don't
want these rappers to keep featuring our
our drink in their videos and we're like
okay fine they created Ace of space yes
yeah yeah and then they just had then
they got the wrong people like if you're
trying to appeal to the black you don't
have the a SP Tommy Hilfiger sounds like
he comes from Aryan land yes yeah to
Somali land no that's that's a call back
guys it is a call back not a good one no
it's okay it's fine it's fine I'm just
still stuck on the dchain gabana that's
going to be put in the soundboard all
right d chain gabana con people hey look
out there comment below don't you
remember the Tommy Hill figure thing
right does anyone here remember that no
you don't remember that okay Matt I had
one Tommy hillfigure shirt when I was a
kid yeah because you were one of the
pores I was yes you couldn't couldn't
afford to couldn't afford to fix your
tooth that was shot out by your cousin
with a BB gun you can't afford Tommy
Hill figure also Fair he was he was
wearing all like the the wrong NBA
championship winner shirts that they
give to all the kids it's sou am I have
Buffalo Bill Super Bowl champs jerseys
what are you talking about Tommy
Hilfiger actually sold rugby shirts to
Americans I remember when I was high
school I was like I got to get one of
those rugby shirts so I look huskier
than I am yeah and then you realize it
is not flattering a rugby shirt it's not
like a baseball uniform that makes you
look big rugby shirts Mak those monsters
look smaller she just giant Stripes yeah
it's cool in the '90s though I also had
jeans with a lot of pockets they were
extreme now constitutional carry okay uh
this is something uh that we've talked
about quite a bit my question for you is
if you support constitutional caring
what that means is that it's not a state
issue you have the right to car if you
are a law-abiding citizen you have the
right to carry your firearm uh across
state lines of course I support it
because the Second Amendment is not a
state issue sometimes you'll get people
saying hold on a second I thought you
wanted a limited federal government
since they only serve to protect rights
not grant them one of the recognized
protected rights is the Second Amendment
you can comment that's my opinion huge
supporter of constitutional carry all
right um and some states pass it on an
individual level I'm there's a national
view of constitutional carry you know
this reciprocity and then of course they
kind of do this constitutional carry I
believe in Ohio is where you don't need
a permit if you're a law-abiding citizen
you can carry uh so a few different
layers here all the references are
available at L credit.com so if you
remember uh you had all these gun
control Advocates sorry not remember
they're still doing it where they
claimed that constitutional carry now we
have some studies would dramatic ly
increase gun violence they called it
wrong how many more lives have to be
lost for the Florida legislature to
finally get the message students demand
action and several Florida house
Democrats spoke against House Bill 543
the bill would remove requirements to
have a permit or training to conceal
carry a gun in Florida and you're more
likely to become a victim of crime
including a victim of gun violence in
States like Texas Tennessee wrong and
Alabama states where you can carry a gun
uh in public
essentially unfettered this decision
will get Americans killed it is a severe
danger to the American people and the
domestic tranquility which is in our the
preamble to the Constitution right this
is not what a well-regulated militia
looks like police officers at the
capital in Austin this morning voiced
their opposition makes our job the jobs
of our men and women more dangerous and
I just want to be clear too when I was
uh referencing earlier there's a
national right to carry which some
people view is a national constitutional
carry law we're talking about State
constitutional carry which is a little
different meaning uh it relates to
permits and you have the right to carry
if you're a law-abiding citizen you
don't need to go through a process it's
if you're a law abiding citizen you have
the right to carry a firearm okay so
Ohio passed constitutional carry in June
uh 2022 and now we have a study uh that
um irrefutably confirms that crime has
dropped and to be clear I know I took
Humanities 1012 correlation as an equal
causation that it Dr dropped the crime
rate directly as a result of
constitutional carry a new study just
released is now unearthing if the
Buckeye State's constitutional carry law
impacted gun violence in cities the
study looked at gun violence in the
state's eight largest cities six saw
less gun crimes after the law changed
now just to be clear I'm know going to
say this bias man the study was
commissioned after mayors of large
cities in Ohio they blamed
constitutional car for the crime in
their cities that's the stupidest thing
that I've ever heard but that's the
starting point that's the reason for the
study and then they missed it by that
much yeah exactly right I lived in
Cleveland for a little while you can't
blame anything on a constitutional carry
law in fact if constitutional carry
would just at least even the playing
field a little bit you have to shoot the
you have to shoot the river when it's on
fire definitely do I blame yeah you
fight fire with bullets that's that's
that's incredible shoot the it's on fire
unload your gun yes yeah the the segment
of the population that is the least
likely to commit crimes including off
duty police officers are the ones that
you don't want armed yes exactly I just
want to make sure I'm clear on the rules
and let me be really clear even if it
didn't reduce gun crime I'd still
support it yeah some sometimes hey
freedom freedom is a I understand
that even if it didn't reduce crime I
would support it just to be clear before
we get some Second Amendment people
saying it doesn't matter no no now this
is also relevant to people who may be on
the fence because we do have some
results the biggest cities uh in Ohio
you have uh Parma gun crimes down 22%
akan it's down 18% Toledo down 18%
Columbus down 11 11.5% Cleveland down
5.8% and I love love for you to hit the
like button signicant signicant hit the
like button if you live in a
constitutional carry state and have had
a positive experience um and this can
you can you are you against uh are you
guys against uh some kind of training to
own a gun because you have to have
training for a car why why why would
that be a car is not a constitutional
right right but why would you just
because it's a constitutional right it's
a constitutional right just like you
don't need training to know how to speak
freely that's the danger of it you can
speak like an you know problem
but that's a little bit different than
bullets cuz I would recommend words and
bullets are a little different but hold
on I would recommend training the
problem with the problem Brian is that
you have to go three steps down the road
and go okay well if I say that training
is now a requirement what are they going
to make training include is it going to
be prohibitive are they going to do it
like ammunition we're like well we can't
regulate the gun sales but we can
regulate ammunition we'll just buy it
all off the marketplace so you can have
all the guns you want you just don't
have any bullets right I guess because
of because of my my training in Kate M
that just didn't happen I had to go
through years of train yes you did you
guys have a minute for
that right thank goodness what you're
also not taking to account is that
happiness itself is in fact a Warm Gun
so here's a
trend I did not know that a warm G it is
happiness is God I like cold steel all
right um we have a national Trend too so
now we have very specific data by
request from the Mayors who said
constitutional Carri is ruining our
cities well here's the study we don't
want it nationally we also have the same
trend line where States uh that have
implemented constitutional carry have
seen fewer gun homicides let's look at
Florida they passed it July 2023 2023
has seen a 10% decrease in gun deaths
versus 2022 Alabama they passed it
January 2021 2023 a 10% decrease in gun
deaths uh compared to 2022 uh you saw
this by the way in Montgomery in 2023
versus 2022 because some of these go to
counties violent crime down about 10%
Birmingham first drop in homicide that
you've seen in uh in 5 years let's go
they killed most of the people that
needed killing I gu that's probably it
just kind of ran out well unhoused
neighbors as Brian refers to them yeah
thank you Georgia they passed
constitutional carry April 2022 2023 12%
decrease in gun deaths versus 2022 top
five safest states have some form of
constitutional carry you may not know
this I've talked about this quite a bit
uh the state that I believe has had it
the longest or certainly one of the
states Vermont no idea Vermont Vermont
you can carry Vermont no Vermont you
need no permit since I believe it's been
since 1791 probably been some variations
you go purchase a gun meaning you go
through the background check which
everyone has to do when you purchase a
gun if you believe that there are no
background checks go purchase a gun then
you'll say oh I was an idiot since 17901
you purchase a gun you can carry it
legally open or concealed yeah because
it's too cold to go outside most of the
time New Hampshire Wyoming Maine North
Dakota these are not bastions of
right-wing extremism just to be clear
these are the safest states now I'm not
saying that these are the safest states
because they have constitutional carry
but that combined with the trend line
that we see in larger states which will
naturally have more crime right States
like Texas States like Florida we see a
trend line of it decreasing violence
it's not really fair to compare Maine
let's say to the entire State of Florida
but we do have some control groups okay
New Hampshire Wyoming Maine Vermont
North Dakota all right this has been the
case for a while now let's apply it to a
very large State all right they're going
to have some more crime because of the
population density large urban areas
gang violence the trend consistently
shows a decrease in overall violent
crime and certainly gun crime so hold on
a second that means that
more guns in
States
C can I get one more Del gabana from you
Gerald Dolen gabana 9 MIM Firearms yes
perfect really and I'm at the bottom of
a well and you just throw me a gun yes I
do I need help wa here you go shoot your
way out fashion yourself a little little
grappling
hook come on mgy come on
mcgyver when they can carry a are you
allowed to carry a sword or a machete uh
now I do often travel with Danny tro but
I use campaign funds you have somebody
else wield the machete for you yes I do
is is Danny if there's a problem
Danny there there are by the way there
are laws to it depends on the state as
far as which knives you can have like in
California they you have these uh
companies that create these knives and
this is the California legal knife and
it just looks like a Whittle down
version It's solid yeah well California
you I guess there's a limit to how long
the knife can be but I believe in
California you can look this up you can
carry a sword yeah like if if the
Blade's over four feet long hard to sit
in a car throws off your whole look that
whole heavy too heavy on my hip people
don't realize that law was lobbied by
big
[Laughter]
nerds I don't even want to I I prefer a
sword yeah okay you carry a sword as
long as you're willing to wear a suit of
armor yeah exactly you're doing cosplay
some kind of chain mail common
misconception you got some you you can
keep your guns that's also
something that you see a lot of people
make these arguments like Shawn Penn
they'll say you know a real man doesn't
need to carry a gun really what about
your security guard Sean what about a
woman yeah is she a coward if she wants
a security guard to have a gun or to
carry a gun hey I don't care if you're
the toughest guy in the world if there's
three gang members and let's assume they
have I don't know a weapon as well it
doesn't matter what you think you're
going to Ben press your way out of it
it's the silliest these are the
platitudes that you see I know you had
some stuff did I didn't let you come in
because no no I mean it the some of the
stuff that I had was really the macro
point right so they would they they're
going to come out with fearmongering
every single time about constitutional
carry or concealed car or anything that
has to do with firearms and then they're
going to come back and say because the
violent crime is going up right we've
just shown you the studies that say that
it's going down but I guarantee you're
not going to see this on CNN you're not
going to see it anywhere you're going to
just have them wait for the next
shooting or the next problem to happen
and then say we need to revisit and have
some common sense gun reform and what
they'll do every single time and I think
we'll get to it here in a second with
New Mexico is say something to the
effect of fully automatic and
semi-automatic they right into that
because every pretty much every firearm
this law that regulates Anthrax and
spoons well hold on yeah one of those is
not like well they use they spoon the
anthrax in I'm not sure that's how it
works so you see this in blue St States
so again despite the results but also in
Gross violation of your fundamental
freedoms they still try and limit the
Public's ability to defend themselves I
wonder why I don't know if you remember
this the New Mexico's Governor there was
a 30-day ban on carrying of firearms
last September and she's now uh back at
it this is from 2024 this is the largest
Public Safety
package ever presented still wearing
mask certainly in a 30-day session
Governor Michelle Luhan Grisham
unveiling 21 bills as part of her Public
Safety legislative agenda the big Focus
gun
her firearm legislation includes raising
the minimum age to buy or possess an
automatic or semi-automatic firearm from
18 to 21 exing the waiting period to buy
a gun to 14 days regulating the
manufacturer possession and sale of
assault weapons and prohibiting guns and
polling places as well as parks and
playgrounds so just to be clear that's
saying uh machine guns and all other
guns except for pump shot guns and some
revolvers bolt action just youan bolt
action yeah okay all handguns
effectively think about that automatic
and semi-automatic and you would be
amazed how many people out there have no
idea that semi-automatic means you pull
the trigger and Boomstick goes bang one
time yes because it's scary
semi-automatic oh my God it's like a
self checkout life's going to be ruined
exactly that and assault rifles right
assault I'm like just Define it please
somebody they say assault weapons cuz
assault rifle has a military term
assault weapon is even broader and means
nothing assault rifle means it has
selective fire in the military uh
assault weapon just means anything that
looks
scary it's absolutely absurd and then
and then they use this to infringe on
your rights just think about that for a
second yeah 30-day ban what carrying
firearms period you can't so they just
said you don't have the right to at all
which if you look back at the Supreme
Court's uh uh case of Hela versus DC
those were the dissenting opinions that
private citizens have no right to own
firearms let's be really clear about the
argument here it's not even about
automatic semi-automatic
it's not about whether you can have a
tank it's not it's it's not about any of
those things it's not about whether you
can open or conceal carry it is about if
you look at the Supreme Court case
whether you have the right to own a
firearm as an American citizen at all
when the rubber meets the road the legal
argument it does not hold water if they
say well if it has this trigger it's not
about an assault weapons ban it is about
whether you have the right to own a
firearm at all so if you line up with
the left ultimately the end of that
trail is you have no right to to own a
firearm we have other states that you
you see this is what they believe
obviously they try to do it in baby
steps California had Nome signed a law
prohibiting carrying in more than like
two dozen public places Colorado they
passed a law restricting ghost guns
which if you don't know what that is
it's like if if if some parts are
actually if you assemble them or you
create homemade parts that a certain
portion it becomes a ghost gun that
being said ghost guns they get a bad rep
you can't help who you fall in love
with
[Music]
I feel like that is it is that such a
better
version that's love was that it that was
is that the sequel that's yeah you know
what all right I don't care tomorrow we
have I think we've made our point
tomorrow we have the uh the marijuana
grow Farm the undercover video uh
Chinese government on the way out like
to the Oklahoma City stuff watch that
video tomorrow and then look at what
we're doing with our borders right and
see that you you have these people kind
of invading our country I know you got
the secure our border shirt on right now
yes we have new these new shirts yet
get over here so yeah we're all SI so
we're sling off mus come back to me
there you go there you go come and take
it the guy the outline the guy looks a
little hippie yeah I'm sure you know
what I mean he's got he's he's not he
should be veed out he's holding a rifle
it's what you do you're you're shifting
weight that's what I say it's hard you
say I want an endomorph holding holding
a rifle so Brian and we're going to play
Spot the transy on mug Club because of
course we cannot play this if it's on on
YouTube you can join mug club uh Brian K
is going to be at the Louisville Comedy
Club March 1st and 2nd you can watch the
show here on Tuesdays and before we
leave because you have the uh uh uh uh
well I let me say this first if you're
watching on Rumble click that button you
join mug Club I'll I'll say piss off
YouTube but don't hit it yet don't hit
it don't hit it because I want the last
thing uh I want Gerald in his Dolce and
gamana voice to uh say your what your
shirt so we'll leave you with this you
can get the shirt at at crowers shop.com
and when you when you see it I want you
to think this come and take
it
[Applause]
what